peu
[Musique]
robin du sibac un tamoul
glenda bon line jet
un reee natif
dont le salon qu'une importante mais il
jouit du quartier résidentiel de ces
villes d'espagne au 8 de la rue emmanuel
chabrier dounia chimène jeune fille de
la haute société fait nerveusement les
cent pas en compagnie d'une demoiselle
du même nom demoiselle de compagnie
dounia elvire que les hasards de
l'existence et la ruine de sa famille
ont contraint au rôle discret de confier
[Musique]
je suis désolé mais dans le version new
look and roll de l'infantile est
supprimé
pendant que la pauvre petite se morfond
mode est dans l'expectative
adam se dérouler dans les couloirs de la
peep a goûté aux compagnies dont le père
de rodrigues et l'otan a dit au
directeur général délégué adecco non
autochtone frau de mélo ont tous bien
que votée mais où je ne te traînes d'un
sextuplé des oies des neiges
[Musique]
comment
et si c'est le cas vous trouverez la
solution des problèmes dans les arbres
couplet de pierre crombez et un jeu 3009
axis vers 16h15 un c-130 économique
surmontant le service naturel
rodrigue seront aussi chez son futur
beau-père au good morning en grèce
seule ville s'engage dans l'armée se
conduisit comme un héros revoit couvert
de médailles d'or droit enfin sous les
onglets appel qu'un king bassa les ponts
rouge en faveur de ses mérites
tu te manquer surmonter les séparaient
le raconte une amie du jeune homme
je vous rappelle que dans la version
américaine des rôles dans la fente à
supprimer le roi un ami personnel de
rodrigues organise un choix tenue en
l'honneur du héros choix rue à laquelle
il convient chimène
[Musique]
prévost chimène dans un coin du salon
n'en perdent pas une miette vous fait
elle résiste et d'augmenter les hauts
elfes îles à sucre ait quelques temps
encore puis à brou soir un soir où les
trilles éthiques
cet effet plus chaudes en accord pour
caresser le cours de ces six bennes se
laisse aller dans les bras d'autres y
[Musique]
est c'est le doge de venise en personne
qui paie ni leur union ensemble ils
allèrent faire brûler un cierge à
notre-dame des erreurs historiques et
tout seul dans son bureau directorial de
castries le roi de conclure devant les
caméras de la dea
froome et mentale et un solo de ce
brevet de boulin baie james et one
prennent peur
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir nous
allons ce soir vous présenter la
première émission d'une série qui doit
en comporter en principe de 176 276 à
raison d'une par mois ça fait environ 23
donc pendant 23 ans
nous allons vous présenter des images
c'est à dire jusqu'en 1987 environ
certaines de ces images sont anodines
d'autres par contre sont franchement
insoutenable oui mais il existe des
documents des documents que nous ne
pouvons vraiment pas ne pas vous montrer
comme ceux ci par exemple qui est
franchement t'as beau minnawi je dirais
même que cette immonde
alors nous n'insisterons pas plus
longtemps sans plus tarder nous allons
vous présenter notre première rubrique
tel va baisser bien sûr de quoi
s'agit-il et bien de la viande de cette
viande qui préoccupe tant notre
gouvernement
jusqu'à maintenant on a utilisé beaucoup
de systèmes aucun n'a marché
on a même été jusqu'à préconiser
l'utilisation de la tenderie soeur cet
appareil qui ramollit le bifteck et
pourtant la tenderie soeur a été lui
aussi un échec pourquoi et bien parce
qu'on a pris le problème à l'envers si
l'on veut faire baisser le prix de la
viande
ce n'est pas la viande qu'il faut
attendrir c'est le boucher attendrissent
et le boucher et le prix de la viande
bay sera seulement la tenderie soeur à
boucher n'est pas un appareil c'est un
principe c'est une méthode une méthode
que nous allons immédiatement vous
enseigner et de petit fake 13200 et pour
vous madame qu'est ce que ce sera voilà
monsieur aujourd'hui c'est mon
anniversaire
alors je me suis dit je vais m'offrir
une escalope au pas une grosse escalopes
n'est pas la folie des grandeurs non pas
une escalope toute simple je dois vous
expliquer j'ai eu une enfance
malheureuse
nous étions huit à la maison mes parents
étaient fonctionnaires et le manger ont
rarement de la viande
[Musique]
pourtant ce soir je vais fêter mes 30
ans seuls
alors j'ai pensé qu'ils d'escalopes
seulement c'est trop cher
alors je me suis dit du courage ma fille
va trouver ton boucher bien sûr il est
intimidant son visage grave sévère
parfois mais mais je suis surtout ce
tamis et blanc il ya un coeur un coeur
tendre d'ordre commun je ne peux pas
installer
par platon boucher me suis répété plus
certaine qu'il te comprendra évoquant
devenue une des escalopes vous ne
refuserait pas dans 10 minutes oui vous
avez curial au monde ne pourrait me
faire plus de plaisir je vous en prie je
vous en supplie diminuer cette escalade
elle sera pour nous comme le pain de
l'amitié que rompait les pèlerins en
route vers jérusalem
cette escalopes ce sera la bière
planches de mes 30 ans elle sera pour
nous le bois rouge du i du mot amour
[Musique]
ce que vous voulez me dire m'attendrir
je suis tombé au plus au poil cette
viande qui serait pour vous plus qu'une
viande anonyme seniors qui serait comme
le célèbre hall de la fraternité humaine
c'est escalopes que vous me demandez et
bien je vous vers la donne le but
escalope
la russie
mais comme liège n'ont rien je voulais à
demain je vous la norme comme je vous
donne ce qu'ils ont dit ne nous rend et
vous en prie acceptez reste mais pas
tous
[Musique]
ce n'est toujours que j'ai en ménage ne
faut pas le roumain seule une petite
cugnaux tiens tu aimes le veau ou elle à
nouveau et le peloton je suis un costume
en voilà du hattgau et voilà de rumsteck
voilà d'humour et encore d'humour voilà
tout bon pour toi mais pas si mon coeur
qui est un abat un abat pour toi
tellement tu es nourris
oui mais je voudrais encore quelque
chose oui à nos noces pour mon chien
chien
[Musique]
savate un départ de la 4e étape du
premier tour d'europe cycliste au yen à
waterloo
étape 3 198 km et à 286 km déjà quatre
hommes se sont échappés
[Musique]
mais n'at on pas de quoi son bidon les
bleus ne passent reconduisant coin j'ai
soif n'est plus fait dit vous êtes tous
les mêmes voulez pas vous charger départ
et après 50 km tout à fait les pas fin
au combat soit pas soit on bison enfin
celui fois c'est pas le moment qu'on
planchon et les envier aux fins
combien d 2 qui sort les engrais une
mêlée tient au dernier pointage
[Musique]
quarante secondes les gars faut mettre
le paquet cambronne fait le forcing 30
ao oui les paroles belfort s'il neige
pointard aux non inscrits pour les coups
pleuvent en fait tout le boulot et cgi
elle arrive à l'état frais comme un
gardon
excuse moi khalid maillot jaune avec les
voltigeurs
mais les bills à l'huile et motos par
une fois comment me dis que nous t'avons
sinon mon contrat ferme là les pédales
[Musique]
on vient dans les creux le méchant le
plafond se départirait forcément il faut
sur un panier je tape cul tu es tout
cela n'est pas que moi confident
et parfois confident coin pas suite au
bilan je salue on a les dents longues et
derrière on chez nous et ils en viennent
à sucer winton qui les ramène les
[ __ ] nous rattrape et on les
prendrait on peut les avoir comme on
veut non on ne peut pas partir sur les
arbres de talleyrand aujourd'hui par un
mot gentil bardet directeur sportif en
battant l'espagnol en fin de course et
il faut attendre leur permission alors
qu'on a la victoire dans l'open nabot
n'a poche a dit qu'on peut se faire
attraper les anglais devront enfin da
costa s'est jamais vu qu on stresse pas
de parler d'envié chez nous quoi
approvisionner devrait perdre au kilo
mais bon bah tant pis pour ta les reins
on fonce la vie dans ce mur
encore un petit effort ou alors dans sa
dizaine à powell tonique de poids senna
pense pas qu'un bidon
tu dois être au mur à ça va être coupé
les pattes on tombe bien on est
maintenant on revient deux minutes sur
301 on croise moins d'un faune devrait
pousser la tactique c'est moi laissez
moi de mer on peut pas partir à 4 contre
euro murat ou pour les autres
un marteau il est temps qu il a cassé
son guidon et grossit jouer dans le
besoin
ça m'agace c'est qu'aujourd'hui un plus
qu'un kilomètre avant waterloo et si on
est parfois mais la victoire facile
alors écoutez moi les petits arrivé à
waterloo
vous mettez en corée vous faites le mur
et moi je vous lâche à 200 mètres de la
ligne avant le mépris non alors si je
gagnais waterloo on se farcit le
classement par équipes où seraient bien
contents on compare à mes grosses on
aime bien avoir le maillot de temps en
temps mais rien qu'une fois tu peux pas
me permettre de prendre des risques
c'est encore le tour de l'île d'elbe à
partir plus les six jours de wagram et
critérium de la bérézina défaut gens
apportent la touche si je veux avoir le
championnat d'europe par points alors
rien à dire
mais senna par trois tombes dont j'ai le
coup de pompe à écrase ça y est les gars
waterloo on arrive même à neuf points à
remonter plus à donner d'autre que les
maillots bon choix c'est ça ou mails
point mousse il alors c'est pas bougé
ces thèmes apprécié un début c'est ici
le vélo municipal de bâtir notre temps
splendide assistance record dans
quelques-uns samba sow jugée l'arrivée
de cete 4e étape du tour d'europe
cycliste mais vassili golovanov de
remonter tout seul comme ne peut les
opus ailleurs suivi le coin de mur anti
massida et c'est le départ de ce prix
avant le tour final hôtes étaient plus
chers ne sera pas à l'aise mais quoique
pénale ans danseuse dernier rappelait en
fait penser la skip merveilleux d'être
remonté
c'est le bonheur c'est la brûlure du
sacre la souplesse dont les jaunes c'est
agréable
j'ai passé l'âge mais j'ai pu faire ça
que j'ai dépassé le bureau et rendre je
vous rappelle donc d'arriver premier
plus cher deuxième napoléon troisième
basse et la murat et quand brad pitt au
but vide plus cher pour la télévision
l'usap ont été les plus surpris on a
fait ce qu'on a vu d'impôts
on a mis le paquet le buteur était en
pleine forme
t'en fais pas à mon vieux pas gagnera
donc faire valoir les âges mais non
c'est pas un désastre
merci les gars vous êtes chouette plus
tard quand vous dirai je t'ai interlock
on n'en fait pas un apôtre était le plus
grandes telles plus fort au merde c'est
peut-être la nappe ou quoi surprendre at
on aille aux riches et bien encore
dernier à grains le tour d'europe pour
moi c'est râpé c'est plus car accroché
mon vélo dans tout plaisante j'ai
vraiment accroché
oui définitivement
alors passez maintenant bidon
j'ai toujours le trac quand
parce que ici m'est arrivé une histoire
merveilleuse c'est ici où pour la
première fois j'ai découvert ma chanson
d'amour c'est vrai vous avez tous
remarqué que nous avons chacun une
chanson d'amour et moi j'ai une chanson
d'amour je l'entends toutes les fois que
je rencontre le grand amour
trois fois par semaine et ma chanson
d'amour à moi c'est la mère michel il y
a deux mois j'étais au canada j'étais
allé assister là bas au congrès du parti
communiste canadien on était deux dans
la salle y avait moi et une rouge une
peau rouge 1 une fille eux le corsage
angers s'est lâché en jersey et le slip
en dire deux n en était qu on allait pas
discuter politique alors je les envie
d'un petit restaurant au bord du
saint-laurent
moi j'avais pas faim lors je les
regardais manger elle avait commandé un
plat de sont payés la choucroute garnie
gremm chantilly à un moment j'avais même
pris une de ses mains pour lui embrasser
le bout des doigts
j'avais choisi la main là - grâce celle
qui tient la fourchette
parce qu'au canada avec l'autre y
poussent
j'avais embrassé sur la bouche pour la
première fois à ce moment là leur caisse
de l'établissement s'est mis à attaquer
un air et vous savez lequel la mère
michel maintenant la mère michel comme
on la chante au canada c'est la mère
michel qui a perdu 100 ch a donc jeté
les gants dans gala gouyette c'est la
mairie ni celle qui a perdu 100 char ge
tank naviguant dans gala couillard celle
d'un moustique lui qui lui a répandu
jetons que ces talibans dont donc à la
cueillette scénaristique lui qui lui
avait produit tant que tels ils vont
dongala quiu ce texte à l'écran dans
tonga les mouillettes tos tombe manicon
dans ton cas de coup dur donc talibans
dont tonga la cueillette de stocks
d'aliments dans gala gouvieux
[Musique]
quand je suis en italie moi je vais
toujours dans la même ville je vais à
milan parce que milan est la capitale
mondiale de l'opéra et moi j'adore faire
acheminer là dedans
mon père était souffleur à l'opéra
municipale de toul et quand tout tout
l'été là j'arrive à la scala de milan
j'avais pu avoir de place à gauche là la
lumière s'éteint chef d'orchestre lève
sa baguette
le rideau s'ouvre vous savez ce qu'ils
jouaient ce soir l'arrêt scala de milan
el gato de la madre mitchell de puccini
[Musique]
ce nul et chatons de la madre nietzsche
et j'atterris tente à la beta est à
cotonou vie de padre lustucru latour
château à bâle a pas de limite sera là
[Musique]
obama
toujours à tous les costumes sans
gwyneth achats reste à coudre et s'ils
ne ferment tôt le biais reste alors qu'à
mourir me reste à wroclaw
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme nous
et encore menti
folio un peu la maman au téléphone ma
mort vient y va si mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle forme pour la boisson offerte et
par qui tu es luxe qui explore l'amour
max martin qui doit soit les la
souffrance de l'abbé soury l'ancien la
mienne parti très fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est drôle que tu es drôle à regarder
et là tu attends un tout fait la tête
moi j'ai envie de rigoler c'est l'alcool
qui monte en maths et l'alcool que j'ai
pris ce soir afin d'y puiser le courage
de tariq jahan l'image de toi et de ton
je suis désolé oui c'est pas du tout
comme ça que c'est amusant va faire le
ménage après j'ai dit c'est pas du tout
ce que nous attendions à mais c'est
comme ça que j'ai appris à 850 mille
personnes qui ont joué ce soir mais
c'est comme ça je fais après moi et vous
l'avez vous appris qu'en bourgogne je
veux gagner un prix avec à oui lequel
un bas le prix de bourgogne ça paraît
logique
c'est pourquoi nous chante autrement oui
j'ai jamais pu vous avoir au téléphone
mais j'aurais vraiment souhaité que ça
soit un peloton chose un petit peu plus
culturel bah je sais pas moi je peux les
deux façons j'ai appris cette chanson il
ya deux personnels une bonne digestion
vous ferez vos émissions plus tard on
amènera plus aussi bon et bien alors si
vous avez une autre version sans moi
j'ai une deuxième version c'est le yacht
ariste de macias il me l'a appris
alors allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
as tu es belle à regarder vers sebha
tombant sur tes chaussures et python
vieux pays normal fermer leur ai dit il
vit rue 10h que jure-t-elle allure à
achever demande chaque jour que match pu
faire pour me faire ma parodie a comme
j'ai pu gagner ma vie entière
écoute c'est bien c'est beau ça tu
ressembles à ta mère a rien pour espérer
là où redites
[Applaudissements]
jacques voudrais quand même vous poser
une question est ce que jamais vous
n'avez entendu cette chanson interprétée
normalement normalement il ya ya deux
mois à new york je l'entends dû
normalement
et ben voilà mais d'une façon formidable
ils ont on n'a pas ça en france à
plaindre
il ya deux mois j'arrive dans un cabaret
sur scène y avait un type fantastique il
la chantait comme ça
[Musique]
you are to be for your eyes be your baby
phone iphone comme ça avec cette idée
que le public du palmarès ne parle pas
tellement couramment l'anglais à part
quelques exceptions à yagg à la chanter
en français comment la chantaient tous
en coeur bat dans l'arrangement du 143e
de ligne croit savoir que vous êtes
occupés marches militaires ont très bien
marché dans notre émission bon à savoir
vous même que vous êtes un ancien du
143e oui c'est exact je viens de bichat
long oui ah oui les les frères mounier
le grand gaillard et castagneur pardon
alors là la 43e de ligne si vous y allez
mon commandant alors au lieu de penser
touchera des tests et donne au pire
comme de la peste
17h pour ces gens qui rôdent
dans l'eau
un bonheur des badauds
d'argent
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous le savez tous vous l'avez appris
par vos journaux l'éducation sexuelle
est maintenant dans les écoles et au
niveau le plus jeune dès la première
année les cours d'éducation sexuelle
seront données il devient dans des
conséquences immédiates
l'éducation sexuelle devait très
rapidement après cette décision
ministérielle faire son apparition à la
télévision
la nouvelle nous est arrivé il ya une
semaine à peu près pierre sabbagh a
réuni tous les producteurs de télévision
et tous ont refusé de donner à la
télévision ce premier cours d'éducation
sexuelle
je ne sais pas pourquoi que ce soit
czerniak ce soir guy lux personne n'a
voulu n'a voulu donner ce premier cours
d'éducation sexuelle alors que je trouve
qu'elle est très très sain
très naturelle d'expliquer aux enfants
comment les enfants viennent au monde et
moi j'ai accepté parce que j'estime
qu'on peut en parler très simplement il
n'y a pas de chichi racer et c'est donc
ce soir sans aucune gêne sans aucune
honte que je n'aurais à la télévision
française
mon premier cours d'éducation sexuelle
mes petits enfants les petits enfants
mais mais mais mais
mais m
si les filets il ya les hommes les les
les hommes n'ont étreignant un peu la
lumière parce que je peux pas comme ça
je veux bien faire mais couper un peu la
vie mais tes enfants les petits enfants
viennent au monde d'une façon très
simple c'est le jeu les taignons encore
un peu la lumière parce que moi je peux
pas parler comme ça il ya trop de
lumière voilà comme ça quand ça va aller
mes petits enfants les petits enfants
viennent au monde mais les écouter et
peignez encore la lumière ça ira mieux
voilà maintenant si je suis complètement
dans le noir
je ne l'expliqué pas mais je pourrais
peut-être nous le faire
c'est toujours agréable de recevoir une
vedette
ça l'est peut-être un peu moins pour
vous de subir le supplice de l'interview
car si la vedette subi le supplice les
téléspectateurs aussi
alors j'ai voulu s'il voulait innover et
avec enrico macias ça ne pose aucun
problème
nous allons pratiquer pour la première
fois et en direct
l'interview musicale
haricots
rires des mois qu ajouté paru
me disais que dire
on y voit en rico où étais-tu passé
je te fais
baribeau des mémoires tout demander des
nouvelles de ta famille
comment va t elle
très bien excuse moi je me suis trompé
dans le texte ne peuvent plus
peu
elle rivaux et hu qui est demain ont
payé deux tiers provisionnels
[Musique]
hélico je sais que tu as en face il ya
tout un dollar
dis moi quel sera le mois
[Musique]
à
à partir du mois de mars indique au voeu
de tous toutes sortes et des dvd
veux tu gagnes la phase où tu vas
chanter
chanteur muet oui
le médecin malgré lui va d'installer et
tout ça sans nous allons dégoûté tu
étais allé pacifique
[Applaudissements]
nous allons terminer taratata avec
claude cenci seulement claude nous nous
sommes penchés sur ton dernier succès
qui va interpréter ce soir nous l'avons
analysé et daniel prévost et moi même
qui avons fait le conservatoire national
de chant dans la classe de yaourt lui
trouve que la chanson tels que tu
interprètes manque si tu veux un peu de
nuance
ça manque de rubato de d'un certain
classicisme alors je ne te donne pas de
conseils mais voit tes aînés nous allons
interpréter la chanson et tu verras tout
de même qu'il ya quelque chose à en
tirer
attention attendez la fin de la séance
pour tomber les cintres alors c'est une
chanson populaire un claude françois 1
en plus
[Musique]
oc
entre eux
chanson
oui
[Musique]
autre que toutes celles improvisées par
jacqueline maillan et jacques martin
voici le thème un jeune homme et une
jeune fille qui sait mais on était
séparés par leurs familles ils se
retrouvent vingt ans après et après la
petite clochette la france fatidique a
placé je me voyais déjà en haut de la
fiche à vous mes enfants ah bon alors tu
rentres le premier nous oui ça m'est
égal
voilà ton la taper les trois coureurs
d'accord oui allez c'est parti
je ne reconnais pas né s'y fait c'est ma
petite juliette
et louis tu vois depuis les 7 pi c'est
tellement incroyable élan est tombé du
bateau comment me tutoie la manche et du
samaa bien tu sais tu sais pourquoi je
n'ai pas voulu t'épouser parce que nos
parents ne s'entendait pas dit t'es pas
consiste à damas dans moi qui étais
c'était des gens charmants mais qu'elles
ont merdé chez toi mais tu n'es pas sans
savoir j'étais une fille très riche et
faisait une affaire d'argent
je suis ça je n'ai pas voulu céder à ce
chantage tué jean cura contre aix et
livres cette année je suis à venir
mittal a beaucoup ri et je vais te dire
une chose
il m'a paru louche que tu as été nommé à
ce rythme-là ground
je m'occupe a pas de la réflexion de
nice maman gâteau wii et wii domine les
maisons s'écroulent je participerai à la
renaissance de la force al-qods heureuse
autres est trop grand et ben moi tu sais
comme j'avais l'habitude de monter chez
soi par l'échelle après si un trident
les pompiers et j'ai commencé l'an j'ai
été trahi où je disais non plus les
balcons je faisais les trente deuxièmes
et quatrièmes peluche est tombé c'est
normal
et oui hein je ne peux plus mettre de
collants parce qu'on ne fait pas une job
il t'expliquera nos écrans bien mais
quand vous montrez le général en
retraite entre les hommes en sous sol au
fait que toujours
entre tous ses frères toujours aussi au
maire de la mère l'enfant et le phare
lancé cyril et l'april d'après d'étendre
les enfants l'embellie était des jeunes
série mad men à la vie s'est agrandie et
comme moi je suis c'est que j'ai
l'esprit de famille tous et ô combien et
pour cause je l'aide d'un petit peu
c'est pour ça que je donne ma robe des
champs parce que j'ai beaucoup de
travail sont beaucoup de monde à
l'église collet qui l'aurait plutôt vers
une pharmacie annonce qu'il haïssait
d'attenté sur l'a12 et giflée puis quand
j'ai vu que ça remue et plus qui te dit
que la télé dit à l'époque
oui mais juliette je t'aimais bien à
plus de poids dans l'oeuf le oui je suis
désolé mais souley dans le dos
entre la vente renvoie pas retenu les
voir ces jeunes pop
le primat donné le goût de l'histoire je
suis traversé quelques tragédies hosties
et je suis tombé sur et sexuellement et
le marchand de venise tu t'entends bien
c'est très simple en tôle dans un
confort tellement je voyais déjà en haut
de l'affiché puisque il est normal que
je vais mélanger copiner avec othello
étant donné je suis à venir
[Musique]
la direction d'antenne 2 nous a demandé
de faire de l'audience et pour faire de
l'audience
une seule solution du sexe toujours du
sexe je joue je te montre comment tu
l'as trouvé hier soir
oui très beau beau
tu as forcément way we que j'ai compris
je le vois
nous ce qu'on va rigoler ce soir pour
fêter ou qu'on va rigoler bon bah qu'est
ce que j'en fais maintenant de
polichinelle ou est-ce que je range
volatile mais dans un tiroir
[Applaudissements]
jean-paul j'ai dit que tu étais mon
copain parce que j'ai vu que tout à
l'heure tu savais faire des grimaces
tous oui est ce que tu veux me faire
quelques grimaces
je vais essayer de refaire la même
tu me diras si c'est bien non on va
faire un concours de grimaces tous les
deux et c'est le réalisateur qui juge à
toi de commencer vas-y moi j'en fais une
autre comment tu la trouves bosch
magritte assez moche tu es mieux la
diète toi ma jean-paul devant les autres
je vais essayer de la faire
comment tu trouves match sandrine et
qu'on applaudit
thème bien manger oui qu'est ce que tu
me lemieux
moi je vais pas fouiller alors oui
surtout pas c'est normal je bats et puis
ta main s'est dit cassé les dents et je
peux te jure lamy veut il fait bouillir
la lee addy cafouillé tu fais la nuit
lattès vous pourquoi m'avait dit
qu'après ça c'est marrant c'est pour ça
que je vais jouer parce que ça fait
péter oui j'y pensais quand même et ça
c'est marrant oui ya que toi qui
s'arrête dans la famille ya que toi qui
ça arrive dans la famille là qu'est ce
qui fait encore débat va l'école tu
mange à la cantine où tu manges ces
mamans et mabouka l'attentisme
épuisement gel qui prêche et mamma mia
la cantine qu'est ce qu'on mange
et du jura non il va et vient une idée
de ce qu'est ce qu'il veut pas pas comme
métier la haye les rouleurs et maman
qu'est ce qu'elle veut oui mais si la
machine papa et rouleur et la machine à
quoi abaca compris au moins tu es tout
seul tous les petits frères des petites
soeurs
[Musique]
1 trois copains tu as raison
il se fait défenseur nom d'un repas et
pourquoi tu en veux pas parce que tu as
me plaît pas déjà parents du petit
philippe qui arrive et on l'applaudît
très fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a failli tomber dix ans qu'est ce que
tu vas chanter spa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à ses parents
magnifique mais non c'est pas grave
[Musique]
montante à louis hiel qui un papou
takhoukht ne m'en a pas sur mes
chaussures si je me moquer comme ça oui
on sait se voit pas du tout à fait pipi
puis tu sais les chaussures ça va cesser
ne s'affichera pas et des chaussures
angoisse
c'est des chaussures retardement oui ça
va tu as fais pipi maintenant tu es
tranquille
alors qu'est ce que tu chantes qu'est ce
que tu veux un qui a failli et ben vas-y
chante
[Musique]
les mâles et un aquitain car françois
répondu à des candidats qui qui ne me
fera pas de cadeau c'est christian
maxime un personnage haut en couleur ça
va christian on t'appelle christian on
t'appelle maxime qui qui savent à qui tu
es venu avec qui le suisse
il est papa
ah bon j'ai vu avec lui il n'est pas là
pas voulu montrer sa grande tête à la
télé qu'est-ce qui fait comme métier
papa
ce tracé
[Applaudissements]
mais je crache pas dessus je me force à
l'orge postillonne des voix oui
qu'est-ce que tu vas chanter une chanson
[Applaudissements]
nana mouskouri elle chante cette chanson
ah bon parce que j'ai tué mes chansons
de noël mouskouri tu aimes pas les
changements de nanas et comment tu la
trouves tu as eu ton paquet moi je vais
cracher dessus et toi t'es moche et nous
allons accueillir cette ravissante
vanessa regarde comme elle est jolie
fait une grosse bise à philippe là et
vous applaudissez transports
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle et me dit johnny je
m'appelle et me dit je nie
j'ai joué deux parties
et vous tous trou divers sur monnet et
je voudrais vivre avec vous
ma vie
[Musique]
oh
tu t'appelles emilie jolie
mika est éliminé
j'allais
je me mets pas tes
tout y est si noël et qu'il voudrait
dire est mon pari
[Musique]
la non fiction où c'est bien voir c'est
ce que vous visez l'auteur échange on
lui disait cette petite fille chante
très très tôt
[Musique]